my move University YouTube videos are
offered on a pay what you like basis if
you'd like to pay for the use of the
videos visit my website at move
university comm click on the pay what
you like link at the top of the page and
follow the instructions on that page
thank you and enjoy in this video I want
to talk about the activation of acetyl
co a to Melanie Loco a so basically if
you recall from beta-oxidation we had to
activate a fatty acid to a CO CO a which
is the activated form of fatty fatty
acid that could actually undergo the
reactions of beta oxidation similar idea
here with fatty acid synthesis we have
to activate these acetyl co a z' to
their active form which is Melanie o co
a so this is the activated form of
acetyl co a and it's the molecule that
actually undergoes the reactions of
fatty acid synthesis so we start off
with this two carbon a acetyl co a and
we attach this carboxyl group here at
the bottom and that carboxyl group comes
from a bicarbonate and so because this
is the carboxylation reaction it it
requires biotin and in fact the name of
the enzyme that catalyzes this reaction
is acetyl co a carboxylase because of
course like I said it's a carboxylation
reaction and that's why it requires by
biotin and adding a carbon carbon
dioxide group or essentially uh by the
bicarbonate requires energy and this
makes sense to given given that if we're
having if we're kind of getting
ourselves ready for fatty acid synthesis
it makes sense that we're in investing
ATP because we're storing energy so
there energy is available okay cool so
this Melanie Ocoee is the molecule that
is committed to fatty acid synthesis so
since it's committed this step here is
the first committed set of fatty acid
synthesis and because of that is a key
regulatory enzyme in fatty acids so
we'll see more about that later now
Melanie Ocoee is going to be the main
two carbon donor fatty acid synthesis
and what I mean by that is that earlier
we mentioned that when we're building a
fatty acid we're going to continually
add two carbon units at a time
the molecule that's gonna be donating
those two carbons at a time is Melanie
okay it's kind of weird though right
because this is a free carbon molecule
while the three carbon molecule be the
two carbon donor and the reason why is
that first step that first reaction that
condensation reaction actually releases
this carbon dioxide so this third carbon
is irrelevant
in terms of the product that's yielded
so the Melanie way is going to be the
main two carbon donor and the reason why
I say the main two carbon donor is
because it's going to contribute almost
all the carbons to the palmitate that
we're going to be making so of the 16
carbons in palmitate 14 of those carbons
are from Melanie Ocoee the other two
carbons are from acetyl co a and that's
because the first reaction the first
condensation reaction brings an acetyl
co a and a Melanie Ocoee together after
that every single to carbon donor is a
melon Yoko a so I hope that video was
helpful thank you for watching